opponents are three out of 65 against
his slider
he is a strikeout pitcher so at this
point you're saying all right reach back
put him away this is strike three on a
high slider
first strikeout for rodon in a big spot
carlos would tell you that he didn't
want it there but he got away with it
hernandez also swings at everything
that's one of the things that
usually causes him some difficulty this
is actually a hanging slider
fortunately it hung high and out of the
zone that was one of those you better
believe
carlos saw the swing he got on the
slider on a ball and a strike
two out for randall grichik always a
dangerous bat one and two rodonda
grichik
that is their strike three oh he
handcuffed him on a fastball in the zone
and carlos climbs to the top of the
strike zone
to end the inning put a little something
extra on this he was 94.95 and then
all of a sudden hello 97 bye we'll see
how robbie ray
fares against the white sox tonight and
lefty robbie ray
working for the first time in his career
in this ballpark
man on nobody out magical 2-2
swing and a miss to strike out of
madrigal anderson will steal
second on the play at second one down no
score bottom of the first
swing and a miss as ray strikes out
moncada back-to-back strikeouts for
robbie ray
yeah we mentioned both of these pictures
feature a terrific slider and they're
going to get a lot of strikeouts on
their slider
robbie ray slider has been consistent
all year long anderson dancing around
trying to distract ray out at second
2-2 he got him swinging a slider down
and in
and ray strikes out three in a row
the count on guriel jr again the 3-2
and a fastball well hit left center
field
angle giving chase but it's off the wall
on a bounce
and guriel can glide into second with a
lead-off double
tenth double of this season for ludus
and he is now three for five against
rodon so
he likes what he sees from the lefty and
he got a pitch fouled it off and then
gets a fourth seamer right out over the
plate
and it's a muggy humid night in chicago
and the ball is not carrying this is a
pretty good hitter's ballpark
i thought this ball was a little bit
better but it bounces off the
base of the fan single plays it back in
and blue jays have a lead off double now
they've got to capitalize
the dugout looking on as the blue jays
trying to strike first in the top of the
second inning
and the 2-2 to espinal got a change up
and he pulls it through the left side
for a base head guriel had to wait to
see if the ball would get through so
he'll stop at third but what a good at
bat by santiago espinal
yeah it wasn't necessarily good because
he gets a base hit it was good because
he didn't swing at that slider on the
pitch before
he took a nasty slider that could have
been strike three and then he gets a
change up and pulls it
past the diving shortstop anderson it
was a very good at batman a
is rewarded with a base hit and guriel
advances to third they could not
capitalize in the first let's see if
they can do it with the bottom of the
order here in the second
a fastball hit in the air to left center
field
this is plenty deep to get the run home
engel will make the catch
guriel on his way home a sacrifice
fly for davis and the blue jays lead one
to nothing
terrific job by jonathan davis he
shortened up and just put the bat on the
ball
and allowed rodon to supply the power
you don't need a big swing with two
strikes you just put the band on the
ball and he hit it to center field and
cash the net runner from third terrific
job
so now the first big league good bat for
riley adams his numbers at
aaa six home runs in 19 games with
buffalo this year
and three of those home runs have come
in his last
three games even the number nine hitter
in his first big league at bat is making
carlos work
there's the slider to cut down adams
two down in the second well he hadn't
seen it the entire at bat i mean not the
good one not the back foot slider so the
first time he sees it
i mean it's a mystery pick and he
shouldn't really be all that concerned
because
nobody else in baseball hits it so
marcus simeon
two and two that is strike three
he packed in a fastball to end the
inning so carlos a couple of hits
allowed in each inning but back-to-back
strikeouts to close the deal including
this one
makata struck out in the first inning
3-2 swing and a miss won't find out here
as ray strikes him out again one down
another good slider from romney ray
yes that's right at the bottom of the
zone it looks like a strike looks like a
strike
you get ready to go after it and bottom
drops out of it breaks down and in
his 50th pitch of the night 2-2 line to
short and
caught by a leaping bashette for the
second out
boy abreu hit that one right on the
button but beau timed his lead
perfectly he was positioned in the right
spot
now watch how high he goes to pull down
that line driver i mean that was a cool
single in the left field
when it came off the bat and beau takes
a hit away from mcgregor
i like how espinal was jumping with him
at the same time
and boy that was a terrific play by
beshette
yes mani grandal who had a base hit his
last time up
and this time he got him 96 over the
inside corner
seven strikeouts through four scoreless
innings for robbie ray
riley adams a catcher his major league
debut adams battled rodona but
eventually struck out and along at a bat
back in the second in his first ever
big league ab 2-2 on the way
and a fastball driven to center field
it's pretty well hit and it's off the
wall
angle corrals it and gets it back into
the infield but congratulations to riley
adams
he's got a double for his first major
league hit
and the family is here to enjoy that and
what a great moment for riley adams and
it comes against a pretty darn good
pitcher guy that threw a no-hitter
earlier this season
see if andrew vaughan can lock in the
count is two and two
the lefty ray to tuna
he lights it up deep in the right we are
tied andrew gives it a ride
one all in the seventh and just like
that
one swing of the bat ties the ball game
and he hits it out of the park
abram now at third mercedes at second
grand all at first braun gives it a long
ride
center field it is caught at the wall
the sox'll take the lead
abrayus coming home mercedes to third
andrew vaughn's driven in both in the
socks
now need just three outs but why not
build a little more
that one just barely stayed in the park
andrew wong got his fastball
and got most of it but not all of it
carl edwards comes in
eaton with the infield in 1-1
to center field it's on its way to tara
firma
and an rbi single for adam eaton in a
pinch-hit roll
it is 3-1 adam eaton gets just enough of
this
to dump it over their heads drives in a
big run and here is laori garcia with
two on
garcia drills it down the right field
line
nobody's home in the corner yes monty
might get
laughed but no matter
two run triple five to one
a four run lead tim anderson will back
and this ball into right field will
bring home
another run garcia tags on a sac fly
from
tim anderson and it is six to one
for the sox if this holds up well that
was pretty
comfortable win here's simeon 6-1
white sox two outs ninth inning
in here right-hand side adam eaton and
the socks in comeback fashion
with a soaring win tonight against the
blue jays